PENG YING: Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Peng Ying,
and with me today is
my colleague, Nagesh.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Hey.
PENG YING: We're here today to
share with you what we built
for Google I/O. Both of us
are engineers at Google.
And what we like to do
is solve problems.
So today, let's first start
off with the problem that
we've found.
Some of you may already
be familiar with this.
And don't get me wrong,
I love Costco.
Their pizza's awesome.
I love their $1.50 hot
dog and drink.
And I was just this past week
and probably bought enough
paper towels and toilet
paper to last a year.
But every time I go
to checkout, it
seems like utter chaos.
There's carts moving from left
to right, from right to left.
Everybody's pretty much trying
to find the shortest line.
And that was the problem that
we are trying to solve--
checkout.
We think that checkout is
cumbersome and a little bit
inefficient.
So what's our solution?
Well, it's what we're calling
"web and mortar." And today,
we're here to talk about
how it works.
How we built each of the pieces,
the Android app the
interactive wall, the back end,
and some of fulfillment.
And then we'll shed some light
on where we hope this goes and
what we hope to see a little
bit further down the road.
So what is web and mortar?
It's an idea built from
the Tesco Wall.
Web and mortar is this concept
of tying the online and
offline shopping experiences
together.
The most amazing thing about
this image isn't that people
are buying groceries in a
subway station in Seoul.
But it's that they have the
cell signal to do so.
I'm looking at you, San Fran.
Nagesh, can you show
them what we built?
NAGESH SUSARLA: Sure.
It's nighttime, and my favorite
store is closed.
But luckily, the web and mortar
store is here with an
online catalog of the various
products they offer.
And here, I have the top
carousel, and the bottom
carousel, which can
be scrolled.
And when you select a particular
item, it shows the
3D view for that particular
item.
In this case, it's
a leather folder.
Now, when I want to buy it, I
bring up the Android companion
app and I select the particular
color that I want.
So in this case, there
were multiple colors.
So each of them was listed
in a special QR code.
Let's add a few more items.
Now, this looks interesting.
How about the squishy.
I always wanted a Chrome
plushy, actually.
Looks colorful.
And I can even scroll it
3D here if I wanted.
I want to add it into my
cart, scan the QR code.
There it is.
Buy with Google, choose
a credit card.
Goes to the next.
And I submit the order.
And I'm done with
the purchase.
Now that we've looked at
the entire flow, let's
look at how it works.
Now, for the buy flow, we used
Google Wallet Instant Buy API.
Now, the beauty of the API is
it is seamless in the sense
that it does not require you
would change your back end.
If you already have an existing
payment provider, you
do not have to change it to
integrate with Google Wallet
Instant Buy.
What that means is if you accept
credit cards, you can
take a credit card from Google
Wallet Instant Buy and pass it
through your back end without
making any modifications.
Now, the other aspect which is
very important is you do not
have to do the credit card entry
and management, like
expiration dates.
Credit cards have expiration
dates and various other
[INAUDIBLE]
which you don't have
to deal with.
You can let Instant Buy
take care of that.
Now, the other more interesting
is that Google
Wallet Instant Buy returns a
one-time virtual proxy card.
So it's not the user's
actual card.
But it's actually a one-time
use card, which is a credit
card which can flow
through your--
PENG YING: Customer security.
NAGESH SUSARLA: It's
more secure, too.
Exactly.
So with that, let's see how
the code looks like if I
wanted to make a purchase,
First, I would get my
estimated price for
a particular item.
Call the MasketWalletRequest
or newBuilder.
Set the currency code,
which is USD here.
And call this loadMaskedWallet
method on the Wallet client.
Now, this is giving
me a call back.
Now Wallet client actually calls
Google Play services,
which is installed on
your Android device.
And then gives me a call back
on MaskedWalletLoaded, which
gives me the masked information,
like the selected
credit card that a user has.
So it shows up a screen do the
user where he or she selects
the particular card that
they want to use.
That is selected, and I get back
that detail information.
I can get the shipping
address, if I wanted.
I can get the phone number,
if I wanted to.
And then, based on this
information, I can calculate
the next steps.
Now, next steps.
Obviously, if I'm shipping, I
need the shipping calculator.
So I would send the zip code to
the shipping calculator and
get back a price.
Let's say it's within the US,
so it's $5.50 or whatever.
Now, with that information, I
ask the user to confirm the
purchase or to review
the order and
actually press on Confirm.
Once they confirm, I can make
a full Wallet request.
The full Wallet request returns
me a one-time use
proxy card.
That's the card I can take and
then pass to my back end,
which then puts it through the
payment processor, gets back a
result like success, or
failure, or whatever.
And then puts it through
my order system.
Now, at the end of this, my
server can then return a
signal saying it was successful
and this is the
order number.
I then call Google Wallet
client and say that the
transaction was successful.
And then also notify
the user that their
order is being delivered.
So that's how the Instant Buy
was integrated into the API.
Now, with that, let's look
at how the other parts of
the app were made.
Now, the shopping cart is one
of the most interesting
aspects in the entire app.
And to build it, there were
several small things that were
needed, obviously.
The first one was to
fetch an item feed.
Now, here it says the number
of items that were there in
the catalogue were
very limited.
We fetched the entire catalogue
from the server
using an Intent service.
Then this was stored in
our SQLite database.
And a content provider was
provided to make it clean to
access these items.
Now, the scanning of the items
was done using Zebra Crossing,
which is an open source
library which you can
download and use.
It's a really awesome library
for QR codes and barcodes.
PENG YING: Any sort of codes.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Yeah.
Any sort of codes.
It's a pretty awesome library.
Now, once you have scanned the
item, you can take it and
store it in the shared
preferences.
Last but not least was the
swipe-to-dismiss item.
If you want to take off items
from your shopping cart, I
really like the gesture way of
removing it, swipe to dismiss.
And all that I had to do, thanks
to my colleague Roman
Nurik, was to just add two lines
into my application to
get this all done.
And in addition to this, all I
had to do was add a few more
lines in a class.
And I got all of it working
within 10, 15 minutes.
PENG YING: Seems
pretty simple.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Yeah.
It was very easy to integrate.
Now with that said, let's move
on to the interactive display.
PENG YING: Thanks, Nagesh.
So we created interactive
display using a few
components.
The UI is comprised of two
carousels, a top carousel and
a bottom carousel.
They contain the same
amount of items--
actually, the same items.
And in the middle, there
is a Detail section.
So the reason we went with two
carousels is because we
thought that we wanted multiple
people to interact
with the display at once.
One thing would be if you had
only one person interacting,
then only one person
can be purchasing.
So why not just double that?
Another thing is it's kind of
interesting to see what
happens when two people are
trying to interact at the same
time, and there's only
one Details page.
Maybe it could lead to some sort
of conversation, maybe
they could be like, oh,
cool, I have that.
You should get it, too.
Or something like that.
To create these sections,
what we used was--
Well, the whole thing
is a web page.
This entire thing
What we're doing is we're
using Chrome Kiosk mode.
And what Chrome Kiosk
mode is is exactly
what it sounds like.
It makes a web page
into a kiosk.
So it removes the action bars,
removes the search bars, and
all that kind of stuff.
And you just get a minimalized
UI that shows a web page.
In addition to that, we did some
other tricks to get rid
of the mouse cursor by replacing
the cursor with a
transparent PNG.
And then what we also did was
we disabled right click.
With a lot of touch screens,
if you do a long press, it
actually acts as
a right click.
And you don't want anybody
long pressing and then
inspecting an element, or taking
some sort of action on
the page that you don't
want them to take.
Lastly, for all of the really
nice physics space, scrolling,
inertial-based scrolling,
we used the
Financial Times Scroller.
It's an open source library,
and it handles touch events
really well.
What we're showing right
here is a simple way
to instantiate it.
Basically what you do is you
define all of the elements you
want to scroll between.
And then you instantiate the
Financial Times Scroller
passing in the dom node and a
few other parameters to define
which way am I scrolling?
What's the size?
Do I want it to snap?
That kind of stuff.
Once we have the interactive
display, we need to feed it
and populate it with elements.
And what we're using is
the same JSON that the
Android app is using.
The way that we formatted it
is we have items, which are
actually the options of items.
And we have an Item Map, which
is the parent item.
So in this example, let's
say the t-shirt
would be the item map.
And then each of the
different options.
Like hey, I want this t-shirt.
And small, medium, or large,
are the items themselves.
In the past, all of this
information, of
course, is in JSON.
So we're using one big JSON
object that contains all of
the items and all of
the item maps.
So once we have the display,
people can browse through it.
They can choose the items that
they're interested in and then
purchase it with their phone.
We need to be able to send this
information back to our server.
So once the person has confirmed
that purchase,
what's happening is that this
JSON that you see here is
encrypted over SSL or whatever
you choose and then sent to
the server.
Within this JSON, we're defining
things like the items
that our customer's purchasing,
their shipping
address, their billing address,
and their credit card
information.
Then, on our back end, we can
take this information and
create a new order, maybe create
a new customer, and
then charge their order, maybe
send it off to fulfillment.
So that's how this all works.
And it's cool.
It's just one of the
possibilities that you can do
with a really simple mobile
purchasing API.
And there's a few more
that we thought of.
What if you can make advertising
actionable?
Let's say that I walk by this
poster for Elysium.
That movie's coming
out this weekend.
I have my phone, and
it's a smartphone.
It knows where I am, all
that kind of stuff.
I tap my phone to the poster and
it shows me a listing of
showtimes around me
and the theaters.
And within a few clicks, I can
buy that ticket, I can save it
to my Wallet.
And then when I go to theater
later that day or sometimes,
instead of going to the purchase
kiosk or going to the
box office or anything like
that, I just walk in, pull out
my phone, show them the
ticket, and then
walk into the theater.
That's a way better
experience.
What about never having to go
to the checkout line again?
So today, what we showed you
was somebody browsing this
interactive display.
What if you just got rid of
the interactive display.
What if the store
was a display?
So all the items within the
store have their own barcodes.
So what if you could just take
your apps, scan all the
barcodes as you add the items
to your cart, and then click
Check Out and walk
out of the store.
That's way better than whatever
clunky self-checkout
experience exists now, where you
take the item and then you
scan it, maybe it doesn't scan,
and then maybe you put
it into the packing area, and
it says, oh, there's some
other items in the packing area
that aren't supposed to
be there, and all that
kind of stuff.
We can make that experience
better.
Lastly, right now, consumers
come to the store.
But what if you could take the
store to the consumer?
The old adage is "location,
location, location." What if
you could combine instant buy
with same-day delivery?
And then you would just bring
this interactive display that
has all of your items, that is
stylized to your store--
pretty much your store
experience.
And then you put it wherever
the people are.
Maybe it's a park, maybe
it's a subway,
maybe it's a bus stop.
And there you have it.
You've taken your shopping
experience.
You have minimal footage,
you have minimal costs.
And then you deliver via
same-day delivery or some
other sort of delivery
service.
Our goal of this presentation
has been really to give you
ideas and to inspire
you to think about
what you can create.
What are the problems
that you can solve?
What are the flows that you can
streamline and simplify?
And basically, what
you can do.
We are here to help you develop
amazing things.
And with that, if you want to
get started with Instant But,
go to
GetInstantBuy.withGoogle.com.
And lastly, follows us on G+.
We're always doing crazy
stuff like this.
We're working on samples, we're
messing around with things.
We're trying to be on the
[INAUDIBLE] edge.
So follow us on Google+ to
see what we're doing.
And thanks for coming and
watching this with us today.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Thank you.